don't you know sense onin REO yeah
Tanaka bokuden nanostick me time you
know y'all where somebody spoke his
language
Wes Anderson has long been interested in
taking meta elements of storytelling and
making them part of the main narrative
whether it's using curtains as a framing
device using aspect ratio to denote
periods of time or a book for narrative
structure for Wes any part of the
filmmaking process seems to have
potential to be brought explicitly into
the story in Isle of Dogs he does this
with translation subtitles are something
we usually consider to be part of the
film's meta like posters credits or
opening production logos they only exist
to the audience as part of the
information surrounding the film not as
part of the story itself but Wes is hard
coding subtitles translation and the
audience's ability to understand
characters directly into the movie this
has its benefits and its downsides which
we'll explore but is this just a
stylistic quirk or if we dig below the
showy exterior will we find actual
thematic significance we get the idea
you were looking for your lost dog spots
there's an intrinsic perspective to any
language in a film that's relative to
the audience in Isle of Dogs West
chooses to use that intrinsic
perspective to his advantage within the
story boku no youna da well I understood
that in the film Japanese is spoken by
most human characters and English is
spoken by the dogs or more accurately
it's stated that the barks are dubbed
into English english-speaking audiences
understand their communication without
visible translation while the Japanese
spoken in the movie is either left
untranslated or requires some kind of
visible in movie translator placing us
in the dog's shoes contextually the
audience literally has to try to infer
meaning based on the behavior and
tonality of the characters speaking
Japanese just like a dog would have to
when trying to understand a human we get
the idea you were looking for your lost
dog spots it's a brilliant way to create
scenes where the audience can suddenly
and ease
imagine how a dog might feel listening
to a human talk I think this was
obviously a significant part of the
Western directors motivation to set the
story within a foreign context the
alternative ways of creating this
language barrier between the dogs and
the humans would have been messy the
dogs could speak their own language of
barks and growls and this could have
been subtitled but that would do less to
allow an immediate identification with
the dogs for the audience the dogs could
speak English and the characters could
speak some type of gibberish yes ma'am
I'd like to be in the spelling bee but
this may be too goofy and require a
suspension of disbelief too difficult
for a lot of viewers the third option
would be the homeward bound option for
both animals and humans speak English
but abstence ibly can't understand each
other this would be very awkward if used
for more than a few brief scenes within
the film wes is using the language of
the characters are speaking somatically
it's not an accident that the character
that is one of the strongest advocates
for the dogs is a native English speaker
speaking the same language as the dogs
is symbolic of an ability to empathize
with the dogs the Tracy character exists
because she's a character that would
speak English the same language the dogs
speak she's there not because an
english-speaking audience needs that
kind of character but because she's
speaking the dog's language to the other
members of the pro dog resistance
symbolically taking a position of
advocacy on the dog's behalf
similarly Atari has a device that allows
him to understand and communicate
directly with his dog this creates a
connection so strong that he's the only
dog owner that tries to find his dog on
trash island
how can you you I can hear you I think
the theme that's buried here is that
being able to understand another group
makes it harder to treat that group and
humanely the odd types of on-screen
translation that Wes chooses to use may
seem like a stylistic quark at first
glance but on closer inspection there's
actually a degree of realism embedded in
how he deploys translation in situations
where no translation would be available
the audience usually doesn't get any and
in situations where we would have
translation it's provided similarly to
how it would be in real life when
watching an international news
conference translation usually comes in
the form of a real-time vocal translator
not subtitles so this is what Wes
provides in the film and when we'd be
reading something in Japanese if we
could we've read subtitles in English
unscheduled junior turboprop in severe
distress reverse para river and when
we're hearing a transmission from a
young boy in the film another young boy
is used as a translator well I think the
way Wes is using language in this film
is clever and unique the unfortunate
downside is that it makes the film's
perspective anglocentric what's uniquely
odd about I love dogs is that even
though it's set in Japan it's created
for an english-speaking context I was
able to read quite a few translated
reviews from Japanese viewers and while
these reviews were overall fairly
positive many viewers noted the
awkwardness and confusion created in the
process of translating the movie back
into Japanese
the Japanese duct version has both the
dogs and the Japanese characters
speaking Japanese uh Nathanial it'll put
enough guns what's this
which harms the perspective of the movie
and completely destroys this scene where
a device is supposed to be able to
enable communication between Atari and
his dog but they can seemingly already
understand each other in the dubbed
version since they both speak the same
language and the end movie translators
simply become useless dead wait for the
film when translating it back into
Japanese use subtitles or a dub here and
your translating Japanese and English
and then back into Japanese making the
translator characters completely
redundant or leave the English
untranslated and let the Japanese
audiences try to make out the faint
Japanese lines in the background with
English on top of it neither solution is
particularly elegant and because many of
the Japanese lines are designed not to
be understood in the film by
non-japanese speakers West felt free to
leave some of those lines muffled or
unintelligible this left some Japanese
viewers straining to understand lines
that were never even intended to be
understood and while all the Japanese
writing quickly flashing across the
screen is just background noise for
other audiences many Japanese viewers
reported being distracted by trying to
read everything the film cinematic use
of language is preserved a little bit
better for foreign releases where the
English can be dubbed and the Japanese
translated in a similar way to how it's
translated in English versions i
especially Joey
the van Eyck's 22 a cute blood bus I'm
watching but because many of the English
subtitles are often a part of the actual
physical animation changing them for
every language would be nearly
impossible and so in foreign versions of
the film much of the text that exists as
part of the world is left untranslated
and these translations aren't vital to
the story but not having them does
detract from the experience but should
the limitations of a technique keep it
from being implemented at all should Wes
have used different methods to try to
construct the perspective of the film as
we discussed every way of giving the
dogs a language the audience can
understand carry some kind of downside
and any film is embedded within a
cultural context for some films like I
love dogs that context might be more
integral to the story I am English
speaking American we'll never be able to
watch Japanese films in quite the same
way a native speaker would while a good
movie can easily overcome the
limitations of experiencing it through
subtitles or CC and even if I learn to
the Japanese I still wouldn't have the
same cultural context a native speaker
would have but should that stop
filmmakers from using that context to
tell stories in inventive and
interesting ways I love dogs is an
interesting case study of this issue
because it doesn't just use another
culture arbitrarily it does so in
service of its story but in doing so it
also makes itself more anglocentric I'm
curious to know what you think in the
comments I personally don't think any
movie can be made outside of a cultural
perspective no matter what the filmmaker
does but should filmmakers try to
minimize that perspectives impact on the
story or is it okay to use that
perspective as a storytelling tool
[Music]
this video is sponsored by an organ by
selecting one of the superfast nord VPN
servers in Japan I was able to browse
the Internet as if I was located in
Japan this made it easier to do research
on the Japanese version of Isle of Dogs
and read reviews left by Japanese
viewers a VPN is crucial to have if you
want to protect yourself online Nord VPN
encrypts your traffic and lets you hide
your internet history from anyone who
might be snooping like advertisers your
ISP or the government Nord VPN is the
best VPN I've used and that's why I
continue to use them you can choose from
servers in over 61 countries and be
instantly secured and protected on up to
six devices at once including your phone
and it's affordable Nord VPN is offering
my viewers seventy seven percent off
three year plans just go to Nord VPN
comm slash Thomas flight or click the
link in the description to sign up and
start protecting yourself
that's Nord VPN dot-com slash Thomas
flight and use the code Thomas flight at
checkout to get started today
thank you so much for watching I want to
give a huge shout out to my patreon
supporters if you've been watching me
for a little while and you like my
content I'd ask you to consider
supporting my patreon so if you're
interested go to patreon.com/scishow us
play and see if supporting my patreon
would be right for you